OK, so let's now continue digging into the
Easter thing.
Slowly but surely, we've learned that Donald
Trump wants to let her rip very, very soon
and get the country open back up.
He wants to do it on Easter.
Now, the absurdity of talking about opening
up a country where 30 states have not closed
anything down is ludicrous and incredibly
dangerous.
I'm getting e-mails from people in Amsterdam
where there are some provisions in place until
June 1 in the Netherlands, hearing from people
in Italy, Spain, so many places, they are
horrified by what Donald Trump now wants to
do.
So they want to open it back up before 30
states have even done anything.
But they also are talking about opening it
back up.
When the death toll is exploding, it's growing
exponentially.
We have case numbers growing like crazy.
And of course, the more we test, the more
cases we will find because we've been under
testing.
But Donald Trump is being very clear now.
He wants churches packed by Easter Sunday,
April 12th.
So look at the evolution of this Sunday night.
Trump tweets, We can't have the cure be worse
than the disease.
We've already covered that with you.
Monday, he tweets, People want to work and
we've got to get him back to work.
Showed you that tweet earlier.
Tuesday, Fox News Town Hall.
Trump floats for the first time.
I'm looking at Easter, April 12th, and then
after yesterday's town hall on Fox News.
Trump was interviewed also on Fox News by
Bill Hemmer.
And he said, I want churches packed on Easter.
Here's the video.
And you'll notice also Trump has adopted a
new voice, which I call Corona Voice.
It's a very unusual delivery, which he uses
when talking about Corona virus related stuff
that makes no sense.
Usually he uses a voice that I think he thinks
sounds empathetic.
It sounds very, very fake.
But when he's delivering news that that equates
to people are gonna die.
Trump has adopted what I call Corona voice.
Take a look.
Take a listen.
Town hall today.
You threw out a date where you think American
can be working again.
And that's Easter Sunday as 19 days from now.
How did you come off with that?
Well, it's 19 days.
But in another seven, because we've been doing
this now for seven.
So that's from the time we heard about seven
in no time.
Well, yes.
So from the time we we close it up so you
can add seven to nine.
Look, Easter is a very special day for me.
And I see it sort of in that timeline that
I'm thinking about.
And I say, wouldn't it be great to have all
of the churches full?
You know, the churches aren't allowed essentially
to have much of a congregation there.
And most of them I watched on Sunday online
and he was terrific, by the way.
But Ortolan is never going to be like being
there.
So I think Easter Sunday and you'll have packed
churches all over a country I think would
be a beautiful time.
And it's just about the timeline that I think
is right.
It gives us more chance to work on what we're
doing.
And I'm not sure that's going to be the day,
but I would love to aim it right at Easter
Sunday.
So we're open for church service and services
generally on Easter Sunday.
That would be a beautiful thing.
My instinct is that if indeed churches are
packed on Easter, it'll be funerals, not for
Easter service.
And I asked yesterday on my Twitter account,
is there any metric or data point that anyone
can point me to that indicates Trump is right,
that we've turned the corner and are now on
the tail end of the.
As he calls it, war against the invisible
scourge or scorch as he has referred to it.
I was hoping someone would point.
Something like even even if it's a weak case
for having turned the corner.
I was hoping someone would respond to me on
Twitter and say, look at these numbers.
Look at those numbers.
We have turned the corner, but nobody could.
And I looked at the numbers again this morning.
Cases are rising every day.
The death toll is exploding every day.
We have more new cases than the day before.
Yesterday, we had 11000 new confirmed cases,
which probably means somewhere between four
and 10 times that in actual cases, because
we're really only testing symptomatic people.
Unless you're rich or famous, the death toll
is exploding.
More death every day.
Deaths nearly doubling from Monday to Tuesday.
Monday we had one hundred and forty one deaths.
Tuesday, we had 225.
There is no responsible metric by which we
are even remotely ready to talk about packing
churches on Easter.
And again, if I said this before.
If Trump said, listen, I really want to open
up some parts of the country to younger people
on Easter, not older folks, not the hotspots,
we've got to get some young people back to
work.
I would say if you want a shot at that, you
need every governor.
All 50 governors to shut it down from today
until April.
Twelve.
Work with me.
Trump should say in all 50 states, stay home,
stay home.
Order shut down.
Non-essential businesses take out only at
restaurants, spacing people out at grocery
stores, all that stuff.
That's what I need you to do to give me a
shot at giving you some good news on April
12th.
It would still be very risky, but it might
be defensible in some way.
Trump saying with 30 states still doing nothing
I want churches packed on Easter is as insane
as it is dangerous as it is irresponsible.
And this is the calculation that they've made.
And what it seems to me is going on is that
they are all skipping all of the headlines
that will happen for weeks and months.
If they do this of the death toll exploding,
of people dying at unprecedented rates, and
that they'll just see the stock market going
up and they'll see an unemployment number
that's not as bad as it otherwise would be.
They will see a GDP decline that's not as
bad as it otherwise would be.
And they're envisioning getting to the other
side of this scot-free and being able to claim
some kind of heroic victory.
I don't know.
Maybe he's right.
I mean, as tragic as it will be.
Is it true that many people in the country
would accept a higher death toll to feel as
though the economy is doing better and people
are working?
Maybe my perspective is wrong.
And when you look at the approval polls of
Trump, which we'll talk about on the bonus
show today, his approval rating is higher
than it's been in a long time.
More than half the country believes Trump
is doing a good job handling this.
Like maybe I'm the odd man out.
Am I the one who says, who am I the one who
is the outlier by saying this doesn't make
sense?
The economic situation that would eventually
recover anyway is not worth killing so many
additional people?
Maybe I'm the crazy person.
Let me know.
We're covering this on our Instagram page
at David Pakman show.
While you're there, you want to see my behind
the scenes video of my home studio setup that's
on my personal Instagram.
David Pakman.
Quick break right back up to
The
David Pakman Show